all right so just a little fine tuning
detail
in
this part on this cd me the knee drops
with the elbow going down so with the
hand dropping so the shoulder goes down
that way you have a homolateral uh
conditioning of your organization you
see so foot knee elbow shoulder all that
goes down at the same time got it and
it's not you don't want to be square at
this point in the edema
you're parallel to his spine
okay
you're here
don't face this way
okay
so the last step the last step
it is imperative that you get on the
inside of his elbow as you come around
you're not just laying this thing down
in order to stay on the inside of his
elbow
my knee has to come towards my other
knee you see and if you look at his
elbow
it is just to
the outside of my spot here's my spine
here's his elbow okay
if you just come around you see your
spine is now on the outside of his elbow
you're not on the inside of his elbow
so your knee has to pass each other
and then goes into chico
and then i'm not going to let you out
this time you'll tap
the back leg the back foot
comes in under
and that is
your turn
that provides pressure from the inside
to his
elbow and then you finish the sheep
[Music]
parallel to his spine
knee
together now your center's on the inside
of his elbow
step up and you have this trap here
okay so use that as a
a benchmark
then the back foot
swings in
i'm not gonna let you go
back foot swings in
and that completes your turn i'll let
you go now don't move more than i'm
moving you though okay don't run away
from the technique
i go in
slide it down the light
that'll end with his hand even with his
head that's another benchmark you can
use
this is incorrect you did not rotate
your person enough okay
all right
let's try it
so remember kihon laza is just a series
of connected
micro drills okay it's not one long
narrative it disappears that way because
really out of a lack of
experience or
knowledge is you can't see all the
little pieces you just see this one long
thing okay
and
when you cut to the end for example you
cut to the end
here like this
you're going like this kind of stuff
it's like you met you left out some key
pieces
okay um
so
though
i'm going to try to motivate you with
these key pieces okay
as i come around
um
and i'm here like this
this hand cannot be going forward
his hand cannot be going forward
because then his elbow is not under my
control you see that
so
if you so
if you bring this off your body you're
almost sure to have it forward then you
get this thing
okay
this hand is going this way
this way
you understand
okay so here here you learn another lock
which here you don't
so here here on my body i have my other
lock
and so this hand is going this way
you see that
not not into where it ends up
starts here
and when i do the chico
right
i have my break
on the wrist
and on the elbow i learned that too
you see do you understand and you don't
learn any of that stuff the other way
that you're doing
okay
the other thing you learn here
is how to let go
and keep control
with your person you can tap when you
don't like it
now i can get my weapon i can get on the
radio
and you can't do that on the other one
got it okay
um
so
here i am so you can actually let go of
the other arm and you could finish the
technique
do you understand
oh it's here
so as i come around now
uh let's look at chico
if you drag your patella on the mat
you will injure your patella that is not
correct chico
okay your patella can only turn on the
mat you cannot slide it on the mat okay
so
as i come around
where's weight
where's weight inside me on the inside
knee not on the outside knee so that's
not sliding on the mat do you see
and now
let's ask if my inside patella slides on
the mat
now it turns it spins on the mat you see
so when you're not attacking the elbow
in this way and you come around like
this
guess what that has to do slide on the
mat okay you can only turn it on the mat
that way you don't get hurt
so your hair
boom it turns on the mat i'm gonna let
him out so i don't break his arm and
this ends
the technique okay so that is the right
way to chico
you have to do it this way and if you do
it this way you get
two more
joint attacks in there you get to learn
them
and uh you get to learn how
to
let go of one hand and keep the same
control and you might have to draw a
weapon you might have to deflect another
strike you might have to talk on the
radio or whatever okay so try it again
okay so as as i come around here
and i project right
you have levels of understanding what is
going on what is going on here i would
say the easiest level why which is the
most commonly understood
is you kind of take his line of gravity
outside his basic support
and he he goes down do you get he loses
balance because his line of gravity fell
outside his base of support
that's not it okay
that is not there's no spiritual
component to that there's no martial
component to that martially what a
person does is they move their basic
support back under their line of gravity
so you don't establish kozushi it
doesn't happen okay
[Music]
the next level of understanding let's
say generally speaking
is you actually are bracing on the map
you're you're bracing he's pushing on
you and you have like a bracing angle
here do you see that and then you're
just gonna overpower him
into this
so i'm on one side and i'm pushing
him who's on the other side again that
is not spiritually uh
worth anything
and also partially it all it will work
if you're stronger than the person it
won't work if you're not stronger than
the person okay
what's actually going on
is
his energy that we say comes down onto
the ground vector do you
that's what the person
the last person i said does not
understand
they think that's bracing okay
his energy is passing through me you can
just imagine like a ghost or something
passes through you you know you've seen
that in the movies
those three to go oh okay it's like that
that's what comes to the ground and that
does not pass through the ground it
bounces back through me again goes
because look and it goes back into him
okay when i enter
his energy is still going through me
it's not me pushing him out of the way
it's me
becoming hidden his energy goes through
me okay so i'll show you what shall we
show you what i mean okay so as i come
around here like this and she's gonna
push on me
okay if i brace and push this i think
you're let's see how strong you are holy
okay
uh you can stand up now
okay and he's gonna push and the only
way i can do this
is his energy is going through me you
can do two hands push okay he's gonna
push and i'm just gonna continually
uh let that energy go through me okay so
when i walk i don't start pushing it
it stays
through me and i just walk
so if he comes around
and you can have so uh
we do the technique
right and he comes around
and again he's pushing holy sh
right away i'm gonna lose because
they're they're stronger than me as i
said if they were stronger than me i
can't do the technique
do you understand okay so he's he pushes
that energy is passing through me that
is why my knees are not
having their patella
shifted
on the mat okay
my knees are not doing anything my knees
are not doing anything
they're not doing anything okay so he's
he's pushing romney can come and push
and he's pushing
my knees are not doing anything
nor is my extended arm my extended arm
is not doing anything
okay and you can
come up
and walk
you have to do
but i'm not saying it's easy to
understand it's easy to understand the
other two models because they speak to
our ego tripartite this does not speak
to our ego tripartite
but
if we say that's energy
it would be weird that energy would stop
at my skin
that is a stranger idea if you think
about it
okay energy passes through us all the
time
all right so
it would this happens too in ground
fighting he's down
we'll be this way
and i'm in the mount and he's trying all
his escapes and i'm trying my pressure
game and the beginner will brace
with her patellas on the mat and it
starts with your hand
it starts to move your leg it starts
rolling it like this
and the beginners are like oh my knees
are all jacked up because you're bracing
on it you're bracing on your patella and
you know what
you don't brace on patella okay so
instead as he's moving i'm moving with
him that's how i'm doing these things
i'm moving with him i'm not gonna brace
and fight against him
okay
so right now when you first start
it's very difficult
if not impossible it is impossible to
not brace on the patella and then the
patella is gonna
do that it gets sore and it's gonna hurt
okay
but as you as you saw you i'm not using
my patella because i'm not pushing
through i'm not pushing through it
okay
all right uh those that did yesterday's
class
if you remember
uh
i had you
uh entering
right and some of you were just muscling
people you don't realize it you're just
muscling people they're like oh
okay you turn
and that's why i had you drop your hand
because
uh in a relaxed fashion right
what did you see
you saw people could if they'd relax
their hand the sky just held it up
well this is that second understanding
you're
just pushing what's in front of you you
understand
but if my his energy is going through me
and because he's tasked with holding my
grip is my hand though
his body has to lower
do you get it so
feel this
and here i relax it's like that thing's
never going to go down
right if i don't know how to do this
let's say you start
push down
but if i can do it
that resistance that he offered his
energy is going through me my hand
lowers he kept his grip
he will fall
i'm not throwing him he will fall
because he's following my hand
okay
it's like that
go